Hi. In this class,
we'll be reviewing some basic lighting concepts
when working in virtual production.
Let's get right into it.
All right, full disclosure.
I'm going to be throwing at you a few complicated terms
and then explain what they mean because I
think it's going to help you understand
how Unreal Engine works under the hood.
Let's first discuss what global illumination means in Unreal Engine.
Global illumination or GI simulates how light bounces around the scene,
creating indirect lighting effects that make
an environment look more realistic.
In Unreal Engine, GI can be either baked,
meaning calculated once and stored,
which is faster but very static because it doesn't move,
or dynamic, meaning calculated in real time,
therefore changing as it gets
either animated or interacted with by a player.
Just so you know, in the same scene,
it is possible to have both dynamic and baked GI.
One doesn't exclude the other.
Now talking about baked lighting,
lighting data in Unreal Engine can be baked on the CPU or the GPU
using the Lightmass global illumination system.
Whenever you hear Lightmass,
it means that the lighting has been baked.
CPU-based Lightmass uses the CPU to compute and generate lighting data,
and it can also be distributed across a computer farm.
GPU-based Lightmass uses your computers and
Bedia GPU to generate those lighting data.
Now Lumen, on the other hand,
is a fully dynamic global illumination and
reflection system that's enabled by default in the Engine.
Compared to Lightmass,
it responds instantly to any moving object and
allows us to iterate our lighting setup without having to wait for baking times,
which can take really long sometimes.
Lumen also provides infinite light bounces,
so to infinity and beyond.
Now, there is a trade-off though,
because Lumen is more demanding on our machine,
and it sacrifices some accuracy for
the ability to have a fully dynamic real-time GI.
In this class, we'll only be focusing on Lumen,
as it's mostly compatible with virtual production and in-camera visual effects.
It's the standard way of working with the Engine,
because it's very fast and it's flexible.
Lumen GI best functions with its sidekick,
Nanite Virtualized Geometry,
or simply referred to by friends as Nanite.
Together, they achieve full resolution shading.
Nanite Simplified Geometry Representation
helps Lumen provide more accurate indirect lighting.
So they really help each other out.
They're best friends basically.
Now, down here, I talk about skylighting.
The skylighting takes care of the ambient light that comes from the entire skydome and not just the sun.
In its last step in calculating the light,
also referred to as final gather in this sentence,
Lumen calculates how the skylight is solved across a scene.
This makes indoor areas properly dark compared to outdoor ones,
and recreates very realistic lighting where interiors only get lit by the sky through openings like windows or doors.
Also, just so you know, Lumen works best with solid objects rather than transparent ones.
When working with translucency or volumetric fog,
the lighting calculations will be simplified and unfortunately not as detailed,
but it's getting better and better.
As anticipated today, we'll only be focusing on Lumen
and we will create a basic lighting setup in an empty level.
Overall, Lumen is going to be your go-to solution when working with lights in Unreal,
but if your machine struggles to compute a heavy environment or your FPS drop below optimal rate,
you could also consider to use Lightmass instead,
either the GPU or the CPU.
The GPU would be faster, while the CPU a little slower.
And also, when working with baked lighting,
you'll be sticking to standard shadow maps compared to the virtual shadow maps with Lumen, unfortunately.
Light baked lighting, standard shadow maps have a fixed resolution for the entire scene.
They're simpler and less efficient compared to the virtual shadow maps,
which adapt to the complexity of the scene and get more detailed the closer they get to the camera.
Now, I said Lumen is well optimized,
but be mindful that if using a ton of lights in your scene,
your performance will still be impacted.
Alright, let's jump into the engine and create our first basic lighting setup using the environment light mixer.
Alright, so before diving into creating our first lighting setup,
we want to make sure that our project is correctly set up to use Lumen.
So let's go up here under Edit and then open up the project settings.
Here on the left, you will find different sections,
and we will find under Engine, a section called Rendering.
Alright, so we want to make sure that first of all, virtual texture support is enabled,
and then we want to check that dynamic global illumination is set to Lumen,
as well as the reflection method set to Lumen.
The ray lighting mode should be set to Surface Cache,
and the shadow map method should be virtual shadow maps.
After that, we just want to make sure that Nanite is turned on.
Now let's go up here in the search bar and type SM6.
Down here on the platform windows, if you're on the Windows machine,
you want to make sure that the DirectX 12 targeted Shitter format SM6 is enabled.
Now if you're on Windows, you should really just take care of this little checkbox down here,
and not the one below here, which is the Vulkan one.
Unless you plan to port your project to Linux or Android,
or somehow your GPU performs better with Vulkan for some reason.
Enabling both of them would just increase compilation time,
as well as the size of the project, so I wouldn't recommend that.
Okay, let's close down this window, and now we can create a new level.
So let's go under File, New Level,
and the level we're going to be creating today is completely empty,
because we want to start from scratch, building our light system.
Alright, now if we go under Window, we can open up the Environment Light Mixer.
Environment Light Mixer is a very simple tool that allows artists to edit their environment lighting components quickly,
and get access to their properties all at once.
So if we click all these little nice buttons over here,
we should be able to create our first very basic lighting setup.
Let's start with the skylight, and Unreal is going to give us an error.
That's just because the sky atmosphere is not there yet, and they're best friends.
So let's move on with the directional light,
then the sky atmosphere, and now Unreal is happy,
the volumetric cloud, and the high fog.
Now if we close the Environment Light Mixer,
we can see that we have a beautiful and well-lit scene,
and we can start building our environment in.
So this is a very quick and fun way to setting up realistic lighting in a scene from scratch.
Now let's go back to our old level by clicking on Levels,
and then open up the Assembly Small Map.
And I'm not going to save these changes.
Now you see this big purple cube up here?
If you click on it, you will see that it is a post-process volume.
A post-process volume allows us to define the overall look and feel of a scene
through some properties that we get exposed to in its settings.
Today, we'll just use it to review different properties we can tweak
to increase the quality of our illumination system using Lumen.
So if we type Lumen up here in the search bar,
we would get access to the Lumen global illumination properties of this post-process volume.
Okay, so I'm going to get a little bit technical here,
and I'm not going to dive too deep into the technicalities
of what each setting of this post-process volume really means.
But if interested, there are some courses that focus only on lighting in Unreal Engine,
so I'd encourage you to watch those if you're interested in learning more about this.
All right, so the first one we get access to is the ray lighting mode,
which controls how Lumen rays are lit when Lumen is using hardware ray tracing.
And right now, we have set it to Surface Cache.
Surface Cache is a memory system that stores information
about the surfaces in our scenes to calculate lighting quickly.
After that, we have the Lumen scene lighting quality, which is set to one.
A higher setting would help Lumen render with higher fidelity,
but it can cost more GPU.
So just so you know, any setting that you increase here is going to have a GPU cost.
We can tweak the Lumen scene detail if we wanted to and increase it to two.
And larger values here would help render smaller objects.
Then we have the final gather quality that was set to two,
so it was increased compared to the default value of one.
The final gather quality helps remove overall noise in the scene,
but again, it can be expensive.
Lastly, we have the scene capture cache resolution scale,
which is a scale factor for the Lumen surface cache resolution for scene capture.
Again, the higher this value, the more it's going to cost GPU-wise, so be careful.
Okay, we're ready to go back to our slides now.
Now, we've already taken a look at how to enable and disable NANIT on our assets,
but let's just review it one more time in the engine.
All right, so I'm going to be selecting my usual rock down here
that we have selected also in the previous video.
Then I'm going to clear out my filters.
So I want to be able to navigate to the place in the content browser
where this asset is stored by clicking on this little icon down here.
Okay, so now if I right click on this asset, like in the last video,
if I navigate up here, I can either enable or disable NANIT on it.
If I wanted to, I could also select multiple static matches like this four,
and then right click on all of them, and you can see down here
that we could disable NANIT on all four of them if we wanted to.
Okay, now let's double click on our boulder,
and then let's review one more time that if you search for NANIT,
up here you can also enable or disable NANIT support
from the static mesh editor settings directly.
All right, we're done with our review on NANIT,
and we can switch back to the slides now to conclude this video.
So that was it for this class.
Thanks to Sean Spitzer for the creation of this lesson.
You can find some additional documentation at this link
if you're interested in further expanding your knowledge
in Lumen Global Illumination.
I'd also encourage you to take a look at our courses focused on lighting
on our platform, because they will dive into these concepts in better detail,
and they're pretty cool.
Thanks for sticking around, and in the upcoming lesson,
we'll be looking to editing assets in the engine.
Bye!